Jag körde kampsport under många år och då var det något som kallas för brottaklara, det är att det kliar på benen när man börjar svettas.
Då var det någon på biblioteket som tror att den här krämen funkar.
Men det funkar det, men ni slutar med den.
För jag gissar att jag var den enda kunden som köpte den här jävla krämen.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160-miljometer.
Jag är ju Chernobyl-generationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har renda språk.
Ni har inga sura kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då välkomnar vi Andrea Olofsson från Hudoteket till podden.
Tack så mycket.
Och jag har ju noll koppling till Hudoteket, kan man säga.
Det är ju inte alls min bransch.
Nu ser ju inte alla mig, men jag är ju en rynkig och icke hudvårdsfokuserad människa, så jag tycker det här ska bli väldigt spännande.
Det är inte för sent.
Aldrig för sent.
Men däremot så när jag sa hemma så sa jag till min flickvän att jag ska intervjua Hudoteket och då sa hon att det var de som lärde mig hur man plockar ögonbrynen.
Härligt, vad bra.
Så detta är ju över 20 år sedan som hon gick till, eller hennes mamma tog med henne då till er salon, Tällan är det kanske.
Hon är härifrån Jönköping.
Jajamän, hon är från Jönköping.
Då berättade de hur hon skulle ta hand om ögonbrynen och göra att hon skulle använda nattkräm eller natt.
Precis, precis.
Kommer man till oss får man lära sig mycket.
Jag tyckte bara att det var väldigt roligt att på något sätt visa det på er bredd.
Att ni har både den här e-handelsgrejen, men ni har också antagligen ett väldigt djup förankring i kanske framförallt Jönköping och bland människor som har vuxit upp och som känner igen namnet på det sättet.
Vi brukar säga att vi följer ofta människor genom livet.
De kanske börjar komma till oss tidigt, de kanske vill ta håll i öronen och sen kanske de får problem med huden i tonåren.
Och sen kanske de ska ta studenten och sen kanske de gifter sig och liksom sen vill de fortsatt göra någonting med huden för att de har fått hudproblem i vuxenackna och så vidare.
Så att vi kan verkligen följa personer från ung ålder till jättelänge.
Så det var jättekul att höra om din tjej där att vi hade fått lära den det.
Ja, det var lite häftigt faktiskt.
Ni har funnits extremt länge.
Eller framförallt nu för tiden har ni funnits extremt länge.
För nu är alla väldigt, de har inte funnits så länge.
Så hur länge är det ni har varit på marknaden?
Sedan 1972.
Det är 54 år, nej 52 år.
Något sånt.
Ja, precis.
Men var det ni från början?
Nej, då var det en kvinna som hette Ingjärd, som drev hieroteket, då var det en liten salong i centrala Jönköping, på 47 kvadrat och sedan skulle hon flytta med sin man till Japan.
Då letade hon runt bland skolor uppe i Stockholm och ville ta reda på vem som skulle passa att ta över hennes bebis.
Så då hörde hon sig för och fick då min mammas namn.
Och hörde då av sig till min mamma och sa att hej vill du ta över min salong och mitt hem och mitt djur och min bil.
Här är en flygbiljett.
Kom ner och gör business.
Jaha, fan vad häftigt.
Och på den vägen är det.
Och din mamma kände att, men det här är rimligt.
Jo men det tror jag, det var 22 år gammal och liksom, Hon ville vinda sig för livet.
Köpte ett aktiebolag.
Så att det är jätteimponerande.
Men då var hon i Stockholm och hade inte en tanke på att hon skulle driva business.
Jag skulle ha haft din mamma här känner jag också.
Ja men hon har mycket att berätta.
Det är ett avsnitt i sig.
Har ni gjort, nu svävar jag lite, men har ni gjort en del content med din mamma där hon får berätta om det här startresan och sånt eller?
Ja men det har vi, men det finns ju så mycket att berätta och nu så har vi ju själva ett födelsagsfirande här inom kort och då tror jag faktiskt att vi har lite extra content om just detta för det är ju en story som är rolig att berätta om.
Ja det är ju väldigt ovanligt.
Men, och hur länge har du varit med?
Sen födelsen, såklart.
Och har ju vuxit upp på huroteket.
Började ju såklart med att hänga med och sen så började jag jobba extra på sommarloven med att rengöra badkar och vika handdukar och gå ner med sopor i källan och allt sådant.
Och sen så har jag liksom jobbat extra på gymnasiet, jag började extra i butiken kvällar och helger efterskolan och lärde mig jättemycket av det.
Men sen så gjorde jag en liten avstickade och flyttade till Göteborg och pluggade och jobbade därifrån.
Så nu sista vändan, jag har varit i biblioteket, så är det kanske drygt tio år.
Hur besviken var familjen på att du smet iväg där eller tänkte de att du kom tillbaka?
Jag vet inte, det var ingenting som de sa i alla fall.
Jag tror att de tyckte att det var bra att jag gjorde någonting annat och fick testa på och det är ju liksom värdefullt för Hudoteket idag, det som jag gjorde där emellan.
Då var du på Nelly.
Precis.
Passar ju ganska väl in för att idag är ni väl, jag gissar att ni inte säger primärt en e-handel men den största omsättningen gissar jag kommer från e-handeln.
Absolut, det är det.
Vad handlar det om, typ 60-70 procent?
Majoriteten är absolut från e-handel, sen så kommer salongen i Jönköping och sen sist kommer vår lilla senaste juvel i Malmö.
Vi ska hamna på alla den där stegen sen, vi ska inte hamna riktigt där än.
Men du jobbar som vd idag.
Ja.
Och det har du varit hur länge då?
Åh två, tre år.
Åh tre år, okej.
Och hur stora är ni idag?
För 2023 omsatte vi 51 miljoner ungefär, vi har varit uppe på 53 miljoner, för en tre och en halv som mest, 2020.
Ja.
Och innan du kom in här i vd-rollen, vad var det du som hade hand om e-handeln då?
Eller vad var din väg in i vd-rollen?
Så att säga, du var inte från att städa ett badkaret till att helt plötsligt bli vd.
Nej, nej men när jag kom ifrån Nelly så skulle det bara vara, det var för att det var ett föräldravick, det var en på marknadsavdelningen som gick på föräldrarlighet, så då tänkte jag att då kommer jag tillbaka och testa och jobba för mamma ett tag.
Och då var det ju främst med i handen de marknadsföringarna och sen så blev det mer e-handelschef, affärsutvecklingschef och sen så trodde jag att det var någon titel operativt ansvarig och sen vice vd och sen vd.
Men sen så är det ju såklart att när man jobbar i ett familjeföretag, vad du har för titel spelar ju egentligen ingen roll för du får ju göra precis allt möjligt i alla fall.
Men du säger att du fick komma till din mamma men ni är flera stycken som jobbar i bolaget.
Det är jag och min mamma, då var det vi som jobbade heltid.
Sen så har jag en lilla syster nu, hon har ju funnits med länge men nu jobbar hon inom företaget som är Hutrapeft så hon driver salongen ner i Malmö och även mycket av våra sociala medier driver TikTok-kontot främst.
Och sen så de andra två.
Pappa har ett annat jobb men han hjälper till med diverse tekniska frågor främst.
Men han har ju också varit med sedan start och då hjälpte han till med ekonomi när det var väldigt litet.
På fritiden också, han har alltid haft ett annat jobb.
Och sen så har jag ju en till syrra som är frädaren.
Som jobbar med något helt annat.
Men hon jobbar inom text så vi tar hjälp av henne ibland när vi behöver extra support där.
Jag förstår.
Ni har inte kastat away henne helt, utan hon har fortfarande en väg in om hon vill.
Jajamän, hon är så välkommen om hon skulle vilja.
Men är alla ni delägare i det här bolaget?
Nej, det är mamma som äger 98% och sen pappa äger någon procent.
De resterande.
Okej okej, jag fattar.
Men det är ändå...
Vi betyder oss ju som att det är vårt företag såklart, men på pappret är det mamma som äger det.
Jag förstår.
Jag är väldigt fascinerad över det här med familjeföretag, för det är lite ovanligt att man gör på det sättet, och det är ju framförallt ovanligt att man faktiskt har en lyckad succession och där bolaget fortsätter.
Men du upplevde ingen press att komma in i bolaget när du var liten.
Nej, nej det har alltid bara...
Är du äldst?
Jag är äldst.
Nej, det har alltid bara varit att jag har velat komma ner efter skolan, och velat få sitta med på produktkurser.
Det har varit jättespännande och en lyx att ha en mamma som har ett företag och en salong mitt i stan med allt vad det innebär.
När man är liten så var det ju jättespännande, men också under tiden man har växt upp.
Så det har inte alls varit en press.
När jag jobbade på Nelly, då jobbade jag där och hade något helt annat på gång, men då var det jag som var sugen på att komma tillbaka och omsätta lite e-handelsidéer i praktiken i vårt egna bolag.
Hur togs det emot?
För hur många är ni som jobbar i dag i bolaget?
Idag skulle jag nog säga att vi är 20 heltidstjänster.
Ja, för då har ju din mamma haft bolaget väldigt länge och hon är ju antagligen ganska nära sina kollegor och man blir ganska tight i en sådan.
Hur blir det när det är ny?
Jag förstår att du inte är ny för att du har varit där många gånger, men hur var det för dig att komma in som vd för bolaget?
Fick du liksom respekt från start eller blev det såhär, det är mammas?
Nej men i och med att jag tror att respekt, det är ju inte någonting som man får bara för att man får en titel, utan det är något som man förtjänar.
Och i och med att jag inte kom utifrån och bara fick en vd titel, jag har jobbat nästan tio år innan jag tog uppdraget som vd.
Och då har ju mina kollegor sett att jag jobbar hårt och vad jag kan och vad jag går för.
Så att det känner jag inte har varit något problem.
Däremot så, eller inte däremot men, men jag har ju, som jag sa innan, jag har ju haft olika roller tills dess.
Och vi har dessutom en styrelse med externa ledamöter så att det blev ju inte bara att mamma valde mig men också för att det var smidigt, utan det var ju någonting som jag blev tillfrågad om.
Och tackade jag till.
Ja, och när du kom in som vd, du har ju säkert suttit hemma vid matbordet, jag bara generaliserar nu, men ni har ju säkert pratat bolaget under lång tid och ni har jobbat ihop och sånt där.
Och man blir ju lite van i att jobba på det sätt som man alltid jobbar.
Sen hade du ju en fördel av att du kom in med handen så det blir ju en nyhet i sig.
Men skulle du säga att ville du liksom bryta med gamla arbetssätt eller ville du förändra arbetssätt eller var det så här, nej men det här funkar och det här funkar inte för jag har varit med i det.
Hur gör man liksom med gamla rutiner och arbetssätt?
Var det så här, hade du typ tre, fyra grejer som du tänkte fan om jag bestämde det här då vill jag bara ta bort den här skiten och så gör vi på det här sättet stället.
Nej men när jag kom in då från början då var jag inte i vd-rollen, men när jag kom och hade jobbat på ett annat ställe ett tag, då kom man ju med fräsa ögon såklart och det behöver man nog alltid även nu om jag hade fått in någon annan som var vd nu hade ju den kommit med fräsa ögon på det och även om vi anställer nya behöver vi ju i vilken roll som helst så kommer de ju in med fräsa ögon och se vad man skulle kunna göra annorlunda.
Så ja jag hade ju absolut saker som jag ville testa men då var vi betydligt mindre, då omsatte vi ju runt 20 miljoner när jag började.
När du började med e-handeln?
Ja precis, fast vi började med e-handeln för jättelänge sen.
Men när jag kom in, då var e-handeln igång redan, men då var det ju enkelt att skruva på lite rattar och se vad som hände.
Men också det här med vd-bytet handlade ju också om att från början var vi ju en salon med lite e-handel, men sen blev vi ju med tiden e-handel med salon.
Och då var det också naturligt att den som satt på vd-posten hade mer erfarenhet och kunskap om vår core-business.
Kan du förklara för oss ungefär hur stor omsättning som ligger på varje ben, eller hur många som jobbar med varje ben, är det lite intressant?
Ja, i och med att vi är ett bolag som har nytta av varandra när det kommer till avdelningar, så är det inte jätte...
Avgränsat?
Avgränsat.
Vi har ju en jätteduktig inköps-
och marknadsavdelning och där inköpen sköts ut till alla.
Marknadsföringen, de jobbar ju med alla delar.
Jobbar man på i våran butik kanske man också hjälper till och skapar content.
Är man på lagret, så kan man också få hjälpa till med annat.
Där tycker jag ofta de som jobbar hos oss att det är kul att man får den här mixen och att man kan vara delaktig i alla delar.
Men jag skulle nog säga att om man ska hårdra det så kanske det är fem på lagret, fem på kundservice, fem på salongen, fem på marknaden, ungefär så.
Men allas roller är lite suddiga i kanterna skulle jag säga.
Nu har ni ju expanderat e-handeln här under ganska lång tid.
Eller det är ju den kanske som har fått ligga lite först i fokusområden.
Men ni gick in i Malmö med en ny salong för inte alls länge sedan.
Nej, ja precis.
Det var inte länge sedan men ja det har vi gjort.
Men är det liksom en del av en ny strategi eller var det för att ni märkte att Malmö de vill ha oss?
Nej, det var faktiskt så att Olivia, min lilla syster, hon studerade till huvudterapeut i Malmö och fattade tycke för den här staden.
Jag förstår, jag har också haft en lilla syster där.
Precis, och tyckte att här ska vi klart ha en salong.
Då kände vi att vi inte finns i någon av Sveriges större städer.
Då kan det lika väl vara Malmö, och jättebra med en familjemedlem som driver det.
Så på den vägen var det.
Det var mer spontant.
Ja men faktiskt, det var en möjlighet som öppnade upp sig och vi tog den, och det är ofta så vi har jobbat.
Och skulle du säga att det har gått bra, nu får du inte sälja ut din lilla sista där men...
Men hon är ju jätteduktig, om man kollar på hennes recensioner påbokad direkt så är det ju bara, bara lovord så att det är ju fantastiskt roligt.
Men går ni plus?
Ja men det gör vi, det gör vi.
Det går plus.
Men sen så när man startar någonting så är det ju alltid startkostnader i form av att köpa höga hyllor och fixa lokalen och så där.
Jag fattar, men på någon slags rullande, rörliga utgifter och fasta utgifter så, så funkar det.
Hur gjorde ni för att bibehålla, liksom, Hudoteket, är det en, är Malmö en liten klon av Jönköping eller är det en egen, en egen touch där nere?
Olivia är ju en liten klon av mamma, vilket är jättebra när man ska driva salong.
Så på ett sätt blir det ju att man, man får ju verkligen Hudoteket uppleva sen i form av service och kunskap.
Däremot så är ju den mycket, mycket mindre.
Det är ju Olivia som jobbar där tillsammans med en samarbetspartner som är sjuksköterska.
Så där har vi inte hela det sortimentet som vi har i Jönköping, utan där är det mer fokus på professionell hudvård och makeup.
Kontra då i Jönköping där vi har mer friskvård, massage, frisörer och jättestor butik.
Så den salongen är super mysig och också centralt i Malmö på Gataplan.
Det är ju något som inte har i Jönköping.
Eftersom ni har både massage och ni har hela den här hudterapeftgrejen, det är en ganska personalintensiv bransch eller genre.
Jag har ju drivit gym tidigare och även haft massörer och sånt där.
Jag vet ju att det är ju vd-värdigt svårt att få folk att prestera bra under lång tid och boka upp sig själva och stanna kvar i flera år.
Hur har ni jobbat för att faktiskt få det att funka?
Det är ju ett ständigt pågående arbete.
Det var ett politiskt svar men...
Nej men mamma har ju, hon har ju gjort det här sedan 1981 när hon tog över.
Hon har svart bälte i att lägga schema och pussla och det här med att kombinera då att det ska funka.
Man vill vara tillgänglig för kunderna att ha öppet när de vill komma men samtidigt så måste det ju, för att vara en attraktiv arbetsgivare måste man ju försöka få till ett schema som funkar för den som ska jobba hos oss.
Så att det där gör hon strålande bra och jag tror att det är därför som folk gillar att jobba hos oss för att vi är måna om att det ska funka.
Ni försöker inte dra in folk som är 18 år som ska jobba stenår till två år och sen sluta.
Nej men det är ju jättekostsamt att lära upp ny personal och i och med att vi också är väldigt måna om att det ska vara att man ska vara välutbildad, man ska kunna produkterna och kunden ska få resultat.
Och oavsett om det är att de kommer för en massage eller en ansiktsbehandling så måste vi lägga jättemycket tid och resurser på att utbilda dem.
Så givetvis så är vi måna om att behålla våra personal.
Hur utbildar ni dem?
Alltifrån internutbildningar till att de får gå på utbildningar med externa varumärken.
Så det är en mix såklart.
Binder man upp sig då för att ni ska få tillbaka den investeringen?
Nej, det ingår ju såklart i att...
Sen beror det på om någon helt plötsligt vill göra något helt annat.
Det är väl en annan sak men generellt så är vi ju en arbetsplats där man får lära sig mycket.
För vi har ju också så många märken.
Det är ju ovanligt att man som hudvårdssalong har den bredden på portföljen men det är ju också för att vi har i handen.
Men är det vanligt att folk försöker sno era personal?
Det vet jag inte, men många som har slutat vill ju sen komma tillbaka och det säger ju väldigt mycket.
Jag fattar, det är ju trevligt i alla fall.
Det kanske inte var alltid gräset grönare.
Om man går in och kollar er ett bolag så gjorde ni en ganska fin tillväxtresa när ni gick in i e-handel och sen så, eller jag bara gissar att det var...
Vi har ju drivit e-handel i 25 år.
Okej, för några år sedan.
Kanske när ni fokuserade på e-handel, jag bara gissar.
Ni har ett ganska stabilt bolag, ni ligger någonstans och taktar runt 50 miljoner och ni går alltid plus.
Men senaste åren så ser jag att det har varit en ganska, det har varit en liten plattår där.
Jag bara tycker det är intressant.
Är det så att ni gillar hur ni driver företaget nu och det är så här ni vill ha ett bolag, det finns inget fel i det.
Eller är det att det har varit någonting som sitter fast eller letar ni nya steg eller är det svåra konkurrenter?
Hur går tankarna kring tillväxt kontra, vi är nöjda med den här situationen?
Jag tror att det är farligt att bli nöjd.
För även om vi skulle vara nöjda med att ligga på den nivån så måste man ju alltid sträva efter att bli bättre för att få behålla den platsen.
Annars kommer någon annan och vill ta den.
Så att där är vi inte så att vi står stilla.
Men det är också en kombination mellan det här att ibland växer man snabbt och mycket, men ibland måste man också underhålla och förvalta och förbereda för framtiden, investera och kratta man ner sen.
Och vissa år är det så att det kommer projekt som kanske inte syns utåt men som är saker som man bara måste göra.
Och så de senaste åren har det varit mycket med olika saker som har hänt i omvärlden som har påverkats.
Och givetvis som företagare är det alltid något som stör.
Men den som vinner är den som fortsätter knega på trots allt som stör.
Men jag tänker, om man kommer från en historik som salong till exempel, då finns det ju bara ett visst antal kunder du kan underhålla i den salongen.
Inte om du frågar min mamma alltså.
Hon började på 47 kvadrat och sen blev det en våning till och sen blev det en våning till och sen blev det en våning till och sen blev det en salong på en golfklubb.
Och sen köpte hon en salong i Värnamo.
Och sen har hon kommit på att hon kan jobba med skönhetsresor, åka med kvinnor utomlands.
Så det finns ju väldigt mycket möjligheter inom det lilla har jag fått inspireras av.
Funkar du likadant?
Jag tror att vi kompletterar varandra väldigt bra.
Ja, så nej då.
Jag ser också väldigt mycket möjligheter, men jag tror att jag är nog lite mer att jag...
Men vi kompletterar varandra på det sättet att hon kanske ser en lokal och säger yes den tar vi, vad fyller vi den med?
Medan jag kanske växer på tills vi verkligen behöver den här lokalen.
Så det kompletterar varandra, så kan man väl säga.
Ja, och din mamma är kvar i bolaget nu och jobbar hela tiden?
Oh ja, och efter att jag blev vd så har ju hon ännu mer kunnat jobba ännu mer.
Många tror kanske att hon har tagit sig tillbaka och tar lite chill, men nu jobbar hon med kunder majoriteten av sin tid och älskar ju hon.
Så det är kunder hela dagarna för henne.
Åtståndsutveckling.
Jag är som sagt bara väldigt intresserad av det här med hela successionsdelen.
När du har din mamma på plats och du fortfarande är där och hon ändå verkar vara en ganska visionär människa, hur jobbar man med det för att det inte ska klascha?
Eller hur gör man för att det ska bli en fin balans?
Har ni något arbetssätt som ni gör detta?
Pratar ni på något speciellt sätt?
Har ni någon viss sorts möten som är uppstyda på något visst sätt?
Hur gör man för att, eller är det bara att det bara funkar?
Det är ju inget fasigt.
Men vi tidigare har varit så att hon har varit väldigt fokuserad på salongsverksamheten.
Och jag är den allra bäst, hon har ju jobbat med den sen 1981.
Och jag kom in och har mer jobbat med e-handelsbiten.
Så där har vi både jobbat med helt olika saker och på helt olika adresser.
Så det har liksom inte varit några konstigheter.
Och sen så nu så gör vi fortfarande de sakerna som vi båda är bäst på.
Hon fokuserar på sitt och jag på mitt.
Men vi pratar väldigt ofta.
Det är frukost och lunch och middag, mellankunder och vi ballar grejer.
Men sen så har vi också en massa andra som jobbar i bolaget.
Så det är inte bara hon och jag som sitter och funderar på saker, utan vi har ju ansvariga för avdelning och alla personalen bidrar också med sina idéer och så där.
Så jag tycker att det funkar bra.
Sen är vi ju en familj och det är ju jättemycket positivt med det.
Men man kan ju också vara väldigt rak mot varandra.
Men jag tycker det funkar bra.
Vad är det som inte funkar bra?
Nej men det finns ju inget som inte funkar bra.
Eller som blir svårare med att vara en familj jämfört med att vara en löst sammansatt grupp.
Svår.
Att jularna blir lite sega kanske.
Ja men det är...
Vad såg sig går liksom.
Precis, nej men...
Vad som är svårt, jag tycker egentligen inte det är svårt.
Sen kan det ibland vara svårt att veta, okej, nu ligger du på soffan och kanske vill ha lite återhämtning här i julldagen, medan jag vill diskutera jobb.
Att ha den balansen i mig att ni är så många i företaget som är, eller i familjen som är inblandade i företaget.
Men det är ju liksom inget stort problem skulle jag säga.
Utan det är ju framförallt en yndest och en fördel att få jobba med de som man tycker om mest i hela världen.
Kan du uppleva att det finns en press här nu?
Nu har ju du kommit in och tagit rollen som vd och du har jobbat i bolaget under lång tid.
Är detta nu också din bebis?
Såklart att man inte kan bestämma allting nu men men skulle du, ser du det som tänkbart att någon gång gå vidare och göra ett helt annat jobb?
Eller har detta blivit liksom, ja detta är också mitt livsprojekt nu?
Nu är det det.
Det är inte min bebis, jag skulle med säga att det är en stora syster.
Okej.
Det är liksom mammas första bebis som alltid jag varit med.
Men jag tycker också att när jag funderar på andra möjligheter och vad jag skulle vilja göra istället, ofta kommer jag fram till att, men allt det här kan jag göra på uroteket.
Allt det här som jag tycker är roligt, de möjligheterna har jag på uroteket.
Och dessutom att få möjligheten att jobba för sitt eget företag, eller för familjens företag eller mammas företag.
Det är jättelyxigt.
Så än så länge så tycker jag att det här är mitt projekt.
Jag förstår.
Den här styrelsen som ni har, vad är den sammansatta av för personer?
Det är mamma såklart.
Och sen så har vi en extern styrelseordförande som bor i Göteborg.
Och styrelseprof så har varit inblandad i en massa företag och ägare och driver.
Jättejätteduktig.
Så han är ju den främsta som vi har externt då.
Och sen så är det min pappa som är med på ett hörn.
För han har ju också alltid varit med, han har ju hela historien.
Och sen så beroende på vart vi är någonstans så har vi ju tagit in andra människor, kanske inte i styrelsen men som har suttit med när vi har haft våra möten, som rådgivande.
Och ibland tar vi även in personal som får komma med sina åsikter och sådär.
Skulle du säga att det fyller, eller vilken funktion fyller, för jag har ingen styrelset till exempel, utan det är bara jag som hittar på att det här blir bra.
Men vad fyller det för funktion när det ändå är ni som är så bestämmande?
Jag tycker att det är bra att man får en liten reality check ibland.
Att man har någon annan som kan komma med ett annat perspektiv.
I och med att vi är familjen och vi jobbar med familjen hela tiden så tycker jag att det är värdefullt att...
Kan du komma ihåg något sådant perspektiv?
Kan du komma ihåg någon sån uppvaknande?
Eller är det en fin fras?
Det behöver inte alltid vara ett uppvaknande utan också en bekräftelse.
Okej, vi tänker såhär.
Skulle du från ditt perspektiv tycka att det verkar vara en bra idé?
Ja, det tycker jag.
Det är inte helt orämmligt.
Ska vi gå in i ett nytt projekt?
Är det här ett bra upplägg?
Tycker du från din synvinkel?
Jo, men jag har varit med om lite annat.
Det har funkat ungefär såhär.
Mycket som vi gör och har gjort genom tiderna har vi aldrig gjort förr.
Då är det såklart värdefullt att ha med någon annan som kan komma med ett annat perspektiv.
Men det är ju inte alltid bara i styrelsen, utan då kanske jag känner någon som har gjort det eller gör inget samtal eller jag har blivit en gubbe eller gumma någonstans.
Ja, jag tycker att det är lite intressant varför man väljer att ta in styrelse.
Alla säger ju alltid att, ja, nu är ni såhär stora, nu måste ni ta in en styrelse.
Men sen så har det ju också, i och med att vi har funnits så länge så har det ju funnits perioder som har varit bättre och perioder som har gått sämre.
Och då kan det ju vara bra att som sagt få in någon annan som kan titta över och se, hur ser det ut?
Finns det någonting som vi kan ratta på och göra annorlunda?
Och nej men Anders han har varit jättevärdfull.
På lite längre sikt, vad tror du är de stora utvecklingsmöjligheterna för bolaget?
Vad är det ni kommer växa någonstans eller var är det ni kommer bli bättre?
Vi jobbar ju varje dag på att bli lite, lite bättre på det som vi faktiskt gör.
Vi har inga planer på att göra något helt annat.
Utan vi har ju våra ben med salong och webbshop, butik och showroom.
Och vi kikar också på lite andra möjligheter framöver.
Så några nya saker finns?
Ja, det kommer vara några nya saker när det kommer till vilka varumärken man jobbar med och hur man jobbar med dem.
Så att vi kommer ju fortfarande att hålla oss inom vår nisch, men fortsätta göra den lite bättre hela tiden.
Och kanske liksom...
Vi vill göra vår nisch lite bättre hela tiden och hitta nya grejer att jobba med som ändå passar in i nischen.
Ja, det är ändå detta som är huvudfokus.
Ja, precis.
Behandlingar, produkter och att sälja dem då.
Ja, och det här med att ha någon sorts omnikanal har ju varit sjukt hypat nu senaste åren.
Förut skulle ingen ha det och nu ska alla ha det.
Ni har ju gjort detta i...
Vad sa du?
Tjugo år, 25 år.
Ja, i handen.
Så ni har ju kört omnikanal längre än de allra flesta.
Finns det någonting som du tror att folk tänker fel kring när det gäller att starta en butik?
För oftast är det en e-handel som startar en butik, då kanske i nuftiden.
Men finns det någonting de missar som de inte tänker på som du tror är stora fallgrupper?
Det beror ju helt på vad det är för typ av service man vill erbjuda och vad det är för butik.
Om det ska vara en butik som har generösa öppetider och som kan erbjuda en viss service så kräver det ju såklart mer.
Och är någon sjuk så ska du ha en ersättare.
Man är inte lika bra på personalfrågan egentligen.
Nej, det är ju en utmaning med att ha någonting fysiskt kontra att ha en e-handel.
Är det någon som är sjuk på lagret, ja då får de andra packa lite mer.
Men är någon sjuk i en butik då står den ju tom.
Och det är ju inte bra.
Så jag tror att det är helt beroende på vad man vill erbjuda för koncept såklart.
Ja men det är en rimlig grej.
Jag tror att det är många människor som underslättar hur krångligt det är att bibehålla personaltätighet.
Ja det är det ju.
Och även om för vår del, vi har ju funnits sedan 1972 på samma adress, men folk flyttar, det flyttar i nya.
Man kan inte luta sig tillbaka och tro att alla vet vart vi finns, alla vet vilka vi är.
För att det händer ju hela tiden väldigt mycket i en stad när det kommer till vad som händer i människors liv också.
Och hur gör man för att hålla sig, jag ska inte säga trendig men liksom, så att det inte bara är Agata 92 som känner till er, utan att ni fortsätter vara det naturliga valet när någon ska gå och lära sig om sina ögonpryn.
Hur gör man för att skapa den känslan i porten?
Dels så är det ju att vi alltid försöker hålla oss ajour med vad som händer i branschen.
Vi tänker inte in allt som är nytt, för allt som är nytt är inte bra.
Men vi ska alltid hålla oss uppdaterade med vad som finns och utvärdera om det är någonting som vi ska erbjuda.
Sen så har ju inte vi, det är ju inte bara mamma har jobbat länge och får i och för sig väldigt mycket nya kunder för att de vill komma till henne för hennes expertis.
Hon har ju såklart också sina stammisar som har gått hur länge som helst.
Men sen har vi också en yngre generation, både som jobbar med behandlingar men också när det kommer till marknadsföring och när det kommer till olika roller inom bolaget, vilket gör att vi också håller oss yngre och intressanta.
Så jag tror absolut inte att det är bara Agda95 som har kommit till oss.
Men om hon kommer så är hon så välkommen.
Vi hjälper till att ta henne upp för hissen och bär henne upp.
Vi har väldigt många sätt att hjälpa äldre, både när det kommer till salongen men också på våra härliga silversurfare som vi tar hand om på vår e-handel.
För i och med att vi har funnits här i över 25 år, så har vi väldigt många stammisar som ringer och som vill ha hjälp att lägga order.
Jag fattar.
Ni hänger en del på TikTok och sånt där, sociala...
Jag tänker att nu...
Jag vet inte vad man kallar den här gengen men hur...
Man klassar väl även in kanske smink och hudkrämer.
Jag lägger in någon sorts samma grej för att jag gissar att det finns absurda mängder små influenser som lägger ut sina filmer på hur de sminkar sig eller hur de tar hand om huden eller hur de tar hand...
Hur sticker man ut i en sådan värld för det måste ju vara helt...
helt egentligen omöjligt.
Nej men vi...
Vårt sätt är ju att vi vill...
Både såklart när det kommer till TikTok, där behöver man ju inspirera och skapa ett intresse och...
och få folk att fastna för sitt material.
Men samtidigt så vill vi också vara kunskapsöverförande, tänkte jag säga.
Nej men alltså att lära kunderna någonting.
Eller de som tittar såklart.
Där har ju vi våran professionella del.
Att vi kan lära dem om huden och hur man ska sköta den på ett bra sätt.
Och det är ju jätteviktigt att man...
Nu är ju TikTok väldigt brett och det är för alla åldrar men det är ju en väldigt stor yngre målgrupp.
Och att redan där kunna lära personer hur man ska göra med sin hud för att de inte ska få problem är ju superviktigt.
Så att sticka ut, för vår del handlade om att vara dels inspirerande och var konsekventa, men också att bjuda på det här mer professionella influencers och beauty-influencers, de är ju ännu mer...
Är det så man kallar beauty?
Är det det som är changen?
Ja, men det skulle jag nog säga.
De har ju liksom sitt sätt att inspirera och prata om.
De ger mer tips utifrån sitt perspektiv, men vi kan ju mer komma med rådgivning.
Okej, du har det här problemet, då ska du göra såhär.
Så där ser jag verkligen att vi har vår plats och kan bidra med någonting.
Jag hörde ju att ni jobbade mycket med TikTok och sociala medier, men ni jobbar inte så mycket med Youtube.
Nej.
Varför inte, med tanke på att det är världens näst största sökmotor?
Och det ligger ju dessutom kvar på ett helt annat sätt.
Absolut.
Det är också en sak som är på listan av allt roligt som man vill göra, men som man inte har kommit till än.
Så det kanske kommer.
Hur förmedlar man att man är professionell på TikTok?
Det är ju, tycker jag, Olivia superduktig på.
Dels så ser man liksom, hela hennes uppenbarelser är ju, liksom hon har ju ofta sin rock på sig och sina emblem, att hon har en utbildning och sen så det hon säger är ju, hon slänger inte ut sig var som helst utan, Man kan försöka hålla en lite pråpräre stil.
Nej inte prå, alltså vi bjussar ju jättemycket på var, att hon bjussar jättemycket på sig själv och också de andra som bidrar till TikTok.
Men vi kan ju inte säga precis var som helst, utan det som vi säger är ju någonting som finns lite underlag för när det kommer till.
Okej, det här och det här funkar på det här sättet.
Har du den här hudåkomman eller det här hudtillståndet så funkar det.
Det här.
Så jag tycker inte att det är så svårt att behålla en professionalitet.
Men, vi vill inte bara vara professionella som du säger pråper för då vill ju ingen titta.
Nej.
Vi vill ju alltid vara professionella, personliga och visa att vi har den här passionen för det vi gör.
Och den kombinationen tror jag är vinnad konceptet.
Jag förstår.
Hur ser man på alla de här, vad ska vi säga då, professionella konkurrenterna?
Det har ju vuxit upp ganska många bolag på senare tid som har fått ganska mycket.
Enklast är väl att säga Lyko kanske, men även Skin City ligger väl inom denna genren på något sätt.
Och de har ju blivit ganska hypade i media, eller det skrivs ju mycket om dem.
Hur bemöter man sådana tillväxtbolag eller sådana väldigt stora bolag?
Hur gör man för att de inte bara ska ta över ens arena, utan att man faktiskt skapar sin egen...
De gör ju sin grej och vi fokuserar stenhårt på våran grej.
Och där tror jag att det finns ju personer som vill gå och handla på den stora affären med hur mycket varumärken som helst.
Och sen så finns det de som vill handla på den här lilla, mer personliga butiken som vet kläder, som vet vad du har för storlek och som vet vad du har i din garderob.
Och vet vad du heter när du kommer in.
Och där tror jag att det finns plats för både och.
Och vi tror stenhårt på vår nisch.
Och är det där ni har lagt er att, för alla som pratar i telefon och sånt är huvudterapeut, om jag förstår det rätt.
Är det det som är er starkaste nisch, skulle du säga, själva kompetensen bakom andra sidan, telefonsamtalet, eller vad är?
Det är en kombination av kompetensen som både finns då på andra sidan, telefonsamtalet, chatten, när det kommer till någon av våra salonger.
Det är också utbudet att vi satsar inte på att ha alla varumärken i alla tidsklasser, utan vi handplockar ju de som vi tycker är, passar allra bäst i vårt sotiment.
Där är vi jättestolta över de varumärkena som vi jobbar med, för många har vi jobbat med väldigt länge och har en jättebra relation till.
Sedan så, vad sa vi där, kombinationen av kompetensen, utbudet, och också hur upplevelsen är när man handlar hos oss.
Det är lite extra, det är med silkepappret och vi väljer ut prover som passar till din order.
Har du handlat något för känslighud så får du oftast ett litet kompletterande prov i ditt paket som är för känslighud.
Vi har personer som står och gör detta för hand.
Så det är en mer personlig och lyxig upplevelse som vi vill erbjuda.
Det har vi gjort ända från att vi var pyttesmå till nu när vi omsätter över 50 miljoner.
Det är fortfarande den upplevelsen.
Det tror vi kommer att göra att vi sticker ut även framöver.
Blir ni lite då, jag tänker bara nackdelar hela tiden, det är ju lite mitt jobb typ.
Men blir ni lite begränsade då av de varumärken, nu har ju ni jättemånga produkter, det låter som att vi vill prata om att ni har två, så är det givetvis inte, jag gissar att ni har några tusen olika produkter.
Så att det är ju rätt lugnt.
Men jag bara menar, blir ni lite begränsade av att de varumärkena som ni jobbar med måste ligga lite i tiden samtidigt, för att annars så kanske inte kunden vill, när ni säger att vi vill kunna erbjuda de grejerna som vi kanske verkligen tror på eller har koll på eller som vi har jobbat med eller som vi kan rekommendera, då på något sätt begränsar ju det ändå storleken på utbudet eller vad man kan växa med.
Är det en nackdel?
Alltså våra varumärken, vi har ju varumärken som dels är väldigt duktiga på att komma med nyheter hela tiden.
Om man är en kund som gillar att det kommer nytt, så har vi varumärken som är så här, det här är vårt original.
Sen 20 år tillbaka, det är det allra bästa, vi tycker inte att vi ska ändra på formuleringen.
Och många kunder gillar också det, för de har ett problem, de har hittat en krem som funkar och de vill bara ha den.
De blir jätteeriterade när den byts ut hela tiden.
Eller att det är ett läppstift som de nu har hittat äntligen byts ut.
Så nej, vi blir inte alls begränsade av våra varumärken, utan med tanke på att vi har en handplockad portfölj med den ändå bred.
Vi har inte lagt alla ägg i en korg.
Så där har vi olika varumärken till olika saker skulle jag säga.
Däremot så är det ju viktigt såklart att de här varumärkena man jobbar med har varor i lager att vi inte blir begränsade i att sälja.
Och där kände man ju av efter pandemin att det har varit lite stopp på vissa ställen.
Så det är ju snarare det som är viktigt att det finns produkter att sälja.
Jag ska erkänna att jag har faktiskt köpt hudkräm hos er.
För jag körde kampsport under många år och då får jag någonting som kallas för brottaklåda, det är att det klijar på benen när man börjar svettas.
Det klijar fruktansvärt mycket.
Jag ringde runt och mailade alla ställen för att försöka få en kräm som fungerade mot detta.
Jag har testat alla.
Och då var det någon på judoteket som jag ska prata med mina kollegor och så kom de tillbaka två dagar senare och bara jag tror att den här krämen funkar.
Och den funkar, den kostade 500 spänn för en liten jävla tur.
Så jag bara kände att fan om inte det här funkar.
Men det funkar.
Jag har köpt den genom säkert i åtta år.
Men ni slutade med den för jag gissar att jag var den enda kunden som köpte den här jävla krämen.
Så jag måste importera den krämen nu.
Och ibland kan det faktiskt vara så att den kanske får säljas utomlands men den får inte säljas i Sverige av olika anledningar.
Så ibland är det liksom inte vi som tar de besluten, tyvärr.
Men där har du ju då det här exemplet för att du har hittat din.
Och du vill ha den, du vill inte att det ska ändras.
Nej, man kan köpa den i Sverige med en fyra gånger frisätt.
Så jag får köpa den från Danmark.
Fruktansvärt, fruktansvärt.
Vad spännande att höra sen vad det skulle vara för kräm.
Men det visar ju också det här som jag pratat om med den här servicen, att när du kommer med ett sånt önskemål, då vet ju jag, då tar ju våra personal den och så går de och så pratar de om det och så kanske de mailar sin leverantör och så mailar de någon till och så är det som ett lite detektiv jobb på andra sidan.
Och det är ju någonting som vi är väldigt stolta över att kunna erbjuda fortfarande för det är ju såklart resurskrävande.
Ja, men å andra sidan så byter ju inte jag leverantörsen på exaktalvården.
Så vi tycker ju att det är värt det.
Jag tänker lite på det här med kundanskaffning.
Nu tog vi upp TikTok till exempel men vi får se om de spärras eller inte.
Hur ser ni på kundanskaffning i framtiden?
Jag gissar att ni har gått, vi pratade lite här innan, ni har ju gått igenom 50-årshistorik, så ni har ju gått allt från att man pratade typ på torget till att man gjorde reklam i den enda lokala tidningen, till att man började på Google, till att man gick till Facebook, till telefonkatalogen med gula sidorna, man samarbetade med något hotell eller något bar och så där.
Och nu är vi här.
Hur tänker du att det här kommer utvecklas framöver?
Vart är det ni fokuserar?
Vad tror du kommer?
Har du någon tanke på hur det här kommer utvecklas?
Det man ser historiskt som jag tycker är en sanning, både under tiden som jag har jobbat med, och också om man tittar bakåt när mamma var själv, det är ju att vår strategi i alla fall är att inte lägga alla ägg i en korv.
För då blir man ju väldigt, som du säger, beroende av den kanalen.
Förr så var mamma ju den här mixen av att det var radioreklam och det var lokaltidningen och det var mässor och man hade den här mixen.
Jag tror att många senaste åren har varit det det bortskämda mig att det bara går att göra meta.
Det bara går att göra Google och man kan överleva på det.
Men jag tror framöver att man, som man redan ser, att aktörer har fått börja bredda sig.
Det kanske är utomhusreklam, det kanske är att samarbeta med influencers eller olika typer av aktörer som man når kunder på ett annat sätt.
Det räcker ju inte bara att finnas på Google utan man måste ha en bredd.
Både digitalt men kanske också print eller de olika mer traditionella sätten som finns inom marknadsföring.
Och där tror jag att sådana rävar som har varit med länge har ju testat de sakerna och kanske det kanske kommer tillbaka.
Vad kommer tillbaka?
Allt typ som utomhusreklam.
Det var ju ett tag som vi absolut inte gjorde det men nu kanske vi tittar på det igen.
Samtidigt så måste man ju nå folk där de är.
Och givetvis så är man ju väldigt mycket i sin telefon, man är mycket vid sin dator men där är ju också konkurrensen extremt stor.
Så att också möta kunderna någon annanstans där de kanske inte hade förväntat sig att se oss.
Men du pratar mycket om kundanskaffning, det handlar ju lika mycket om tycker jag att ta hand om de du redan har.
Exakt.
Inte bara tänka på att skaffa nya utan vara relevant och aktuell för dem som du har redan i din portfölj.
Jag tänkte lite på det för att du sa att ni ser det lite som att ni följer med personen genom livet, nämnde du här i början.
Jag gissar att ni har en ganska tung databas med gamla kunder, de har ju varit med ett tag liksom.
Har ni något sätt att plocka upp de här kunderna som inte har varit hos er på tre, fem, tio år?
De som inte har varit hos oss på fem och tio år, de finns inte ens kvar.
GDPR rensades.
Vi gallrar såklart så de som finns i våra register, de är ju relativt aktuella.
Nej men givetvis så jobbar vi också med olika typer av sätt att attrahera kunder som inte har varit på ett tag.
Alltifrån att skicka mail till att bjuda in till event, så det finns jättemycket möjligheter där och där tror jag man hade kunnat göra mycket mer.
Men som du vet, tyngden har bara 24 timmar, så där finns ju alla möjligheter.
Men sen så finns det ju ibland också anledningar till att en kund har valt att, det behöver inte vara att de tycker att vi är dåliga, de kan flytta till en annan stad eller om det handlar om just salongsbiten.
Eller så är det en produkt som inte finns längre.
Du kanske inte har handlat den här klodkrämen, men då är ju kanske utmaningen för oss att få det att inse att ditt shampoo som du handlar eller det andra, det ska du köpa hos oss och inte någon annanstans.
Jag tänker när du säger det med shampoo där, att ni måste ju tillhöra kanske den kategorin som har störst mer säljningspotential förutom typ Ica.
Men för att man behöver ju alltid någonting med er.
Och jag gissar att rätt mycket av er metodik egentligen går ut på att få kunden att återkomma ofta så att ni alltid är i någon sorts, kanske inte ofta men i alla fall väldigt regelbundet så att ni alltid är en top of mind och alltid kan fortsätta säljet så att det egentligen aldrig ska ta slut.
Hur jobbar man med att få en kund att, om jag då till exempel köper en klorkräm, det är skönt att prata med alla om att jag klijar på benen när jag tränar men liksom, om jag gör det, hur gör man för att den kunden ska övergå till att köpa det plus en grej till?
För helt plötsligt har man dubblat säljet vid varje tillfälle, det måste vara en enorm vinning.
Ja absolut.
Det beror ju på vart den kommer till oss.
Har vi förmånen att träffa personen i våran butik, då kan man ju informera där om såklart vad som finns för kompletterande produkter, men det handlar ju alltid om att fråga vad kunden har för behov.
Vi vill ju inte packa på kunden produkter som den inte behöver, men vi vet kanske att du ändå ska smörja dig med någonting och tvätta håret med någonting, och då vill vi informera dig om att det finns jättebra grejer här.
Om du har gillat den här kladdkrämen så kanske du kan gilla något mer annat.
Har ni något system för att göra det?
Om ni ser att en kund köper samma kräm fyra gånger i rad under ett år, ringer ni upp en sån kund eller skickar ni...
Nej jag menar inte det på något.
Det skulle ju varit en ganska cool tjänst att bara hej vi ser att du köper alltid den här för Akne.
Det finns andra produkter som du kan kolla om du inte får...
Det finns ju en hårfin linje mellan att det ska ses som en service och att det ska ses som att...
Ja precis, kunderna ska ju känna att det är...
De är anonyma.
Man vill ju hjälpa dem men det får inte upplevas som att nu sitter vi här och håller koll på precis vad det handlar.
Det är en grej att skicka ut ett mail att säga du har handlat det här, du kanske också är intresserad av det här.
Så det är en hårfin linje där skulle jag säga.
Hur hårt jobbar ni med den linjen?
Framförallt så är det ju på e-handelssidan så är det ju uppföljande mail att man ser att du har handlat den här nattkrämen.
Du vet väl om att det finns en dagkräm till.
Och sen så jobbar vi mycket med att också informera om varför det är ett bra köp.
Varför de ska köpa om den.
Du vet väl om att den här produkten hjälper till att minska klimatavtrycket med bla-bla-bla.
Eller du vet väl om att när du köper den här maskaren så går den 10 till de här skylpatterna.
Vi har något varumärke som bidrar med.
Så jag tror att mycket handlar om när man har köpt någonting så vill man ju också få bekräftat att det var rätt köp.
Så att man inte börjar leta efter massa annat.
Så att vi vill ju såklart mer försälja men vi vill ju också att kunden också ska vara nöjd med det de har köpt och se hur man kan använda det.
För de kanske har köpt en nattkräm som man också kan använda som en mask och som du också kan lägga i hårtopparna, vad vet jag.
Så att de blir mer nöjda med det och kommer tillbaka av den anledningen.
Det är ju inte alltid som du återkommer som kund för att vi har informerat om något mer utan kanske för att du bara blir så himla nöjd med både servicen, leverans.
Det är så många steg också.
Det är ju att vara nöjd med det som händer på sajten och hela perioden från att du har lagt ordern till att du får med dig att den är på väg.
Och sen så upplevelsen när du hämtar ut paketet.
Och sen allt efterföljande när det kommer till e-mail, telefonsamtal och om.
Och om det skulle vara något problem så vill man också att problemet blir avhjälpt på ett bra sätt.
Det kan ju också göra att du får behålla en kund eller inte.
Personaliserar man köpresan, till exempel nu för tiden när man köper en bil, eller inte köper en bil men köper tillbehör, så går man ju ofta in på sidan, skriver in sitt regnummer och då kommer de delarna upp som passar till den bilen.
Funkar det så i er bransch att jag kan gå in på er hemsida och skriva att jag har torr hud och jag har akne och jag har, jag vet inte om ni har fler hud på dig, jag är ju så bra på detta, men exem typ.
Får jag då upp produkter som passar till det så kan man göra sådant eller är det ett för stort jobb?
Dels så har du såklart filtrering på sajten och där gör vi ju allt för att också när man är inne på produkten för i dagsläget så kommer väldigt många direkt in på produkten från olika sökmotorer.
Så det gäller ju att därifrån informera om att det finns kompletterande eller har du den här så kanske du också ska titta på den här.
Men sen så har vi också väldigt mycket servicemöjligheter i form av telefonsamtal, chatt, mail, en digital hudanalys där man kan svara på frågor, skicka in bild och få en rekommendation.
Så att där har vi väldigt mycket som vi jobbar med idag men det finns ju oändliga möjligheter med hur man kan utveckla just rekommendationsdelarna, speciellt nu i och med att allt vad AI kan medföra.
Exakt, det börjar ju komma, om närmsta åren kommer det vara lite intressant.
Jag tänker också på hur man gör för att stänga köpet, för jag upplever att er genre lätt blir en browsing genre, alltså att det finns så många alternativ, så det kan vara lite svårt att avgöra om den är bäst eller den är bäst.
Så det blir kanske lite lätt, jag har sju systrar så jag har ju lite hygglig insikt i just det här då, men kanske de kollar på den varukorgen och den varukorgen och den varukorgen, och så vill man ju få dem att stänga det köpet, men vad betyder den ingrediensen kontra den?
Hur gör ni för att faktiskt stänga köpet?
Så att ni får köpet, jobbar ni på något speciellt sätt där?
Vi försöker ju framför allt erbjuda väldigt, såhär, vi vill erbjuda mycket information, men samtidigt så kan ju för mycket göra att det blir svårare att ta ett beslut.
Och det är ju därför vi inte har 50-11 000 varumärken på vår hemsida, vi har kanske runt 60 varumärken på vår hemsida, och även det är ju ibland för mycket om du ska välja vad du ska ha för fuktkrem exempelvis, och då behöver du hjälp.
Och det är där jag tror att många tar hjälp av vår expertis, både i butik men också på telefonnummer och chat.
För ofta så hamnar det ju där att nu har jag de här alternativen och alla verkar lika bra, och alla ligger kanske ungefär samma pris, men vilken ska just jag ha?
Vilken blir bäst för mig?
Och det är där som den sista pushen kanske behövs expertis till.
Men driver ni aktivt era kunder till att ta kontakt med er?
Ni måste se en ganska bra konverteringsrate på dem.
Om de inte vet vad de ska ha så vill vi absolut att de ska kontakta oss så att vi kan guida dem så att det blir rätt.
Sen är det ju huden, alla är ju olika, vi kan inte garantera att bara för att du köper den här så blir det 100% rätt men det kanske blir mer rätt än om du bara hade valt på MoFo.
Jag tänker att vi ska ta några slutfrågor här.
Nu har du jobbat som vd i några år.
Skulle du säga att du har förändrat som person under den tiden?
Nej men jag har ju också blivit äldre.
Jag har jobbat nu på hydroteket i den här senaste perioden i över tio år och det är ju en annan person nu än för tio år sedan.
För att jag har fått lära, man lär ju sig.
Nu har jag intervjuat 25 personer i den här podden eller nånting.
Varenda jävla person har sagt det svaret.
Är det så?
Ja, alla säger ja absolut, men jag har ju också blivit äldre, så jag vet inte vad som är vad.
Men skit i vad som har blivit äldre, det är klart att vi inte är lika impulsiva och konstiga som vi var när vi var barn liksom, men har du som person blivit en bättre ledare?
Ja men det tycker jag att jag har blivit.
På vilket sätt?
Om jag frågar min personal.
Vilket jag gör ofta i och med att jag har olika typer av medarbetarsamtal så brukar de säga att jag är bra på att vara rak och tydlig och det kan man ju kanske bli mer då med tiden för man får bättre koll på saker.
Och att jag låter, alltså jag har förtroende för människorna att göra, ta egna initiativ och ta egna beslut.
Det är också någonting som kommer med tiden ju, tycker jag.
Sen tycker jag på senare år att som inte har egentligen att göra med jobbet, utan också mitt privatliv och jag har nära vänner som har blivit väldigt sjuka.
Man inser att det inte alltid är på liv eller död.
Det är, det mesta går att lösa.
Så länge man har hälsan och får möjligheten att gå till jobbet och göra förändring så är det ju något positivt.
Så det tycker jag att jag har fått lite uppvaknande det senaste.
Att det är oftast inte så farligt.
Det mesta går att lösa.
Jag tror att det är en sund insikt.
Vilket drag skulle du säga att du kommer att behöva de nästa tio åren om ni ska bemöta allt som händer?
Eller som du behöver utveckla mer?
Vart ligger din kompetens eller personlighetsbrist?
Jag menar det på ett snällt sätt.
Jag menar bara vad...
Men jag tycker att att driva företag är ju ofta att lösa olika typer av problem och ta olika typer av beslut snabbt.
Att liksom komma vidare och det har jag ju insett nu i och med att jag också har fått barn att innan har jag ju kunnat lägga hur mycket tid som helst av min fritid, nätter och jag har kunnat ägna saker extremt mycket tid.
Men nu så inser jag ju att nej, ibland måste man bara ta ett beslut, gå vidare och köra på och så får man få det bära eller brista.
Men vi har i alla fall tatt ett beslut och nu utvärderar vi failfast och sådär som man tydligen ska göra.
Men alltså jag brukar vilja ha hängselen i liven och sådär.
Så det ser jag att det kommer jag att behöva bli mycket bättre på.
Jag läste någon bok någon gång som handlade om bolag som hade gjort sin lilla nisch till perfektion.
De kanske var någon lokal restaurangkedja eller de var ett lokal bolag.
Nu är ju inte ni lokala bara utan ni har ju en salong men ni har, jag är bara fascinerad, ni har ju gjort detta under så pass lång tid.
Och ni är lönsamma och ni tuggar på liksom.
Har du något, för väldigt många råd idag handlar ju alltid om hur man skalar.
Alltså väldigt mycket inom entreprenörskapet idag är alltid diskussionen om hur bygger jag ett bolag snabbt och hur gör jag en exit och allt sånt där.
Och vad ska ni göra näst då?
Vad är det nya?
Men jag är lite fascinerad, har du någon tanke eller några råd kring hur bygger man ett bolag som faktiskt är varaktigt?
Jag hade inte med den här frågan så det är okej att tänka någon sekund här liksom, men jag tycker att det är en spännande fråga.
Inse att det är att gå upp varje morgon och jobba på.
Det är liksom hårt jobb, löna sig.
Och det ser ju bara på min mamma då som har drivit det här företaget sedan hon var 22.
Och nu, hon har aldrig trott att det finns någon genvägar eller att det bara ska gå över en natt, utan det är så här, man går till jobbet och så gör man sin grej jättebra och lite bättre varje dag.
Och det tror jag ändå är nyckeln till att det ska vara varaktigt.
Sen så, att hålla det jämnt och bra.
Det som är på baksidan ser man ju inte alltid det här att det är ju inte bara att man gör samma saker hela tiden, bara för att det ser lite jämnt och stabilt ut så behöver inte det betyda att vi alltid har gjort samma saker.
Vi har ju testat oerhört mycket olika saker för att fortfarande få finnas kvar.
Exakt.
Du måste ju ha en tillväxt för att ligga på samma nivå.
Man måste ju hela tiden bli bättre för att vara relevant och för att få yndestän att få leverera paket och få besök av våra kunder.
Så man måste ju fortsätta hela tiden utvecklas, även om man kanske i sitt huvud ser framför mig att den här storleken är bra eller vi vill ha den här nischen.
Hela tiden se utvecklingsmöjligheter.
Det motiverande rådet till alla entreprenörer som vi bygger något från varaktigt är att du får aldrig, aldrig, aldrig sluta utvecklas.
Ja, kanske, var det fel?
Nej, det är väl rimligt.
Men det behöver ju inte heller vara så, som du sa, det snackas ju mycket om såhär, vad är nästa steg och vad är exit och det ska vara så stort och så.
Men det är inte alltid kanske att det behöver vara det utan att, beroende på vad du är för typ av bolag så kanske en, liksom, en ny produkt eller en ny färg eller en, någonting som gör att de kunder som går till dig, hela tiden tycker att det är intressant.
Och nu blir vi lite bortskämda för nu pratar vi som att, 20 anställda och 50 miljoner i omsättning, och E-handel och salong och en till salong inte är stort utan vi pratar som att det är en liten personlig business.
Men det är ju för att vi pratar i break it rubriker och inte i verkligheten.
Det finns ju 120 000 hudterapeuter därute som gärna hade haft den möjligheten.
Precis, precis.
Så, så, jag tror...
Vi kan sammanfatta av det här.
Andrea, det har varit fantastiskt att vara med dig i podden.
Ett otroligt inspirerande företag som ni har byggt upp.
Och någon dag när mina barn är, när får man börja ta in dem på lagret 12, så hoppas jag att jag kan göra samma succession.
Jag tror att det är många företagare dröm.
Tack för att du fick komma.
Tack själv för att du har velat vara med.
Jag ska erkänna att jag har faktiskt köpt hudkräm hos er.